hey guys this dense the powder take care
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of agents of shield the
season finale beginning of the end so
yeah you know I enjoyed this episode
it's like you know we've been talking
about this all like the past few weeks
like the show's been getting better it's
not a great show I don't even know if I
could say it's a good show yet but it
has some potential and has good moments
here and there and it's been getting
slowly getting better yeah i mean sure
eyes it's moments like i said it's just
it's just a stretch to keep trying to
find ways for me to like it I just I
keep trying to look for little things
and they're just kind of falling apart
you know Bill Paxton was something that
was holding on to you for a while I
really like both packs I something he's
awesome we got to see them continuing
with him on to season two but they're
not continuing on with it with season
two oh I mean I'm sorry no I mean that's
right i don't like to see what then it
yeah um yeah loans obvi I got blown up
so I mean I liked him so I liked him but
I don't know I mean I just I don't have
a character that I really interested to
see what happens to them next I think I
mean okay to get the finale credit I did
like Sam Jackson kind of coming in of
course against my movies change action
coming in insane I want you to rebuild
shield do whatever you want with that
was kind of interesting well guess is
that gonna affect the movie universe you
wonder if that's gonna I think it will
and i think there's motivation to in
terms of not just the characters but for
people watching to say okay this is
something that I'm more interested in
versus you know for the first half of
the season it was all about you know
wiseguy special and what you know what
happened to Agent Coulson cuz he died
and came back right right yeah neither
one of those storylines were very
interesting no the storyline didn't
really get interesting until we found
out that Ward was bad yeah we found out
a bill patton bill paxton came in and
became the basically the lead villain
yeah and and then all the repercussions
of the captain america winter soldier
movie and how it affected the shield TV
show right I think that helped helped
propel the show
to tell more watchable yeah the whole
like they called the uprising art yeah
it took a long time to get going
basically a little before cats in
American then Catherine American then
because I mean the whole Thor tying was
that was weird it was like they came to
London after he had made a mess that's
like oh look what he did and that's it
so so specifically this episode would
you like from it what didn't you like
from it I mean I thought they took I
don't know I again they took risk the
whole scene underwater with Fitz and
Simmons and you know kind of sacrificing
a life to save a life kind of a scene
here one of those kind mean that was
interesting again my issue with the show
is I just don't care about the
characters enough to really get into it
but i understand that was a risk i mean
that was an interesting scene I thought
it was you know pretty well acted by the
two guys who were girls read his comic
relief and yeah if it's professing his
unrequited love for you to sim in to you
know if you notice like when she found
out that you know he was gonna die she
kissed them everywhere except for lips
they never got quite that low now but
and I'll I another part well this is
just me personally during that scene or
when they're explaining they figure out
how to escape hmm thanks to time warner
I didn't hear it I don't know what
happened all I know is they were talking
about how they couldn't escape alright
and that there wasn't any they had
exhausted all the options right right
yeah we hear but ya know then the sound
cuts out oh no and I don't hear any of
this yeah and late and it cuts back in
it's like you're brilliant let's do that
and I'm like okay so they so I don't
know how they figured out I'm sure it
doesn't really matter but it was kind of
annoying for me that is a little
annoying cuz in the end I mean fury said
like oh we made this little beacon thing
you're like you know that I saw that
part but like I don't know how they
actually what was the science or maybe
non-science right of how they were
escaping this thing right like I don't
know the mechanics behind how or why
letter Simmons
all right it's got out of the pod and
then went up with Fitz I don't know it
just happened I was gonna say I don't
talk about moments you want mother
moments that kind of liked was Bill
Paxton going crazy I guess as he started
kind of losing his mind when he was
talking to the you know a woman in the
flower dress talking about how like he
sees everything he can see things he he
sees into her soul like him kind of
going crazy because Bill Paxton such a
good actor III like those moments him
kind of losing its going going or crazy
yeah over the top right I liked him just
over overacting he was good he's really
good at that those are my favorite part
I like that I would the one say I didn't
like the most was when Ward talked to
the the girl in the flower dress and
then it just became this thing where I
always hate this one they do it in TV
shows or movies with like they she
purposely says all these vague things
because she knows or they know that the
audience is listening and these are
mysteries to be revealed at a later time
ago oh you know about sky and about
about Garrett like so she's talking
these vague terms that no one you know
in a situation like that would actually
talk to another person right they just
do that because they don't want to
reveal anything to us a lot of you right
so I found that kind of annoying you
guys have some mystery for season two
well and then the weird thing is now
what's gonna happen with ward because
he's locked up and he got shot with the
three times in the foot that was cool i
like to fight saying i like to see yeah
yeah yeah yeah and you know just the
whole like he's like oh i thought you
were the ice queen or there's no strings
attached yeah you know things so I like
I like that part i like i like the
second half of this finale a lot more
what's like Nick Fury came into it and
and saved Fitz and Simmons and then I
think things start moving on from there
appreciate the continuity to I like that
he had I believe I'm a guest mouth same
outfit singing sunglasses end of Captain
America exactly about that was this
episode had some nice hedges again the
show's not the worst show on TV it's
just it doesn't give me any to care
about like I don't really if this show
was cancelled it wouldn't bother me I
mean I feel bad for the exes I don't
anybody be able to work the camera
people everyone's got to work i was
gonna
people going to work but it wouldn't
affect me as a fan I'm like oh man I
really would have liked to see a second
season but but I don't think this is a
bad episode I mean no I enjoyed it for
what it was and I think you know there
is some potential for season two I will
give season to a short leash oh I'll
give it like three 3 four episodes and
see how it goes from there but if they
start on this whole episodic thing again
like oh we're rebuilding shield here's
this mystery or a case of the week thing
I'm out I'm out like you you better
establish right away in the first
episode of season two what the storyline
for the whole seasons gonna be what's
the story are gonna be for the whole CEO
cuz if that doesn't happen in the first
few episodes are all just case of the
week stuff I'm done yeah because I'm not
going through that again I went through
that the whole entire this season right
and then we got some better episodes
towards the end right we don't you know
when we talked about earlier yeah I'm
not doing that part again yeah I mean I
I gave the show a season I said I would
I set it on here I told Dennis I would I
Gator season I don't really care to
watch that she's into just I think
there's also there's a lot of other good
genre stuff coming out yeah I want to
see what Gotham's about okay Gotham
Constantine's about centene we got some
other good comic book stuff hopefully
it's good this unless you tell me yeah
the first of us was like Dave maybe
check it out then maybe I will but this
show hasn't give me anything to hold on
to her think about over the summer yeah
oh is it could you John I really want to
see agent Carter it's things that we
have to wait until the mid-season point
of agents of shield so probably I don't
know december january to see agent
Carter but I really do want to see agent
Carter that hold 1940s beginning of
shield spy thing that could be
interesting I hope I don't know we'll
see oh you're not interested in Skye's
no super DNA or the foot like when her
like I found your daughter like the hand
buddy buddy another keys yet another
t--exactly more cheese all very vague
very vague very vague I want to miss
bill sorry I messed it up in the
beginning i'm gonna miss Bill Paxton
yeah cuz he was one of the main reasons
that I like this yes this last few run
of episodes and so I mean they did a you
know it was a funny joke at the end
blowing him up but at the same time I
like oh that's hilarious right but now
he's really not coming back yeah and
that means you know the best part of the
show so far is gone yeah and that's it
it's not like Sam Jackson's can come in
every episode no no I mean he can pop it
maybe every now and then Oh in this
first season he had a cameo in the very
in the second episode but there was
nothing this was this episode you know
he actually had a part in it yeah he was
shooting guns he was talking to agent
coulson him and Colson him and Clark
Gregg have a chemistry there that's what
we did for the movie yeah yeah I love
Clark Gregg when he was with the Tony
Stark yeah they had great chemistry too
but it's him just by himself trying to
lead this group and he just hasn't
worked for me yeah I do like his a
chemistry with me I think that dynamic
works I think you know I just don't need
to see much more so I Fitz and Simmons
can they can be there just be in the
background yeah you know Ward's gone now
so I guess trip is probably part of the
team he's not he's okay he's okay but
not super compelling either yeah now
where's the compelling villain gonna
come from it's for me it's really gonna
hinge on these these first the show
could use a good villain they could use
a good villain yeah which they already
had no they can continue this Hydra
storyline who's okay who's in charge of
Hydra now yeah we'll see the end of
Captain America Winter Soldier yeah
Robert Redford's character died seem to
be like one of the heads of it you have
you know Garrett Bill Paxton dead now
gone who who is the face of Hydra now
yeah I guess it maybe uh Baron von
Strucker yeah I guess be very very von
Strucker who's working with like his own
secret project so yeah I mean that's
that's why I would think it'd be him
yeah who knows ok yeah alright so yeah
that's our impressions of the season
finale and the whole season in general
let us know what you think are you guys
gonna keep watching it like me like give
it a few episodes are you gonna stop
like David and wait to hear from other
people because there's a lot of people
there's some people that watch reviews
that don't watch the show I know
thinking people just want to see what
we're saying about this the show yeah so
it's it's definitely not a show I'm
telling people hey what you need to
watch this it's not like you know like
Game of Thrones like you've got to watch
game it's right you should watch bored
while she watched justify don't when
free
she was on I was like you gotta watch
fringe yeah yeah you gotta watch sarah
connor chronicles like there's there's
certain shows you like get hyped about
and you're like hey this is not one of
them no could it be in the future sure I
mean just winning shows have done that
to me in the past Buffy didn't get good
for me for a few seasons same with
angels so could it happen sure I just I
just don't have the patience right now
yeah and we'll see there's there's a lot
of looks like a lot of interesting geox
ABC NBC just released all their up
fronts I mean there's some
interesting-looking shows coming out
next year alright guys you can post your
comments below on our website think here
come our YouTube channel think you're a
pro make sure you get to subscribe to
that now you also can find us on Twitter
we're all at think hero and i'm at
griffin de and make sure you like our
facebook page that's a facebook.com
slash think hero fans and make sure you
share our videos on Twitter Facebook and
all that stuff
you